We're going to kick it off
with an amazing story from Atlanta.
I personally made sure we told this story today
because it just did everything for me
that I was looking for.
CNN reports that the city has launched
the largest community food forest in the country.
It's in Brown's Mill neighborhood and it's 7.1 acres,
and it provides over 2000 edible
and medicinal plants to the community.
Onions, garlic, potatoes, tomatoes
so much fresh free food.
And one in four Atlanta residents
live in areas called Food Deserts
because they lack basic access
to affordable and nutritious food.
So this forest is a huge resource
and it's a community center and it's run by 1000 volunteers,
and for many young students
it'll be their first trip to a farm.
And there are 70 free food forests
in the United States so far.
Ross, the reason that I was so passionate about this
is because you want to see the evidence of something magical
and change, and this is it for me.
Well, and it's also just like the baseline
of how we should be helping each other.
There are hungry people who need food, right?
And this sort of food forest provides that for people.
It is so simple that we can take care of each other
this easily, right? We grow it.
And I grew up in an agricultural farm town.
My first job was picking spinach,
then I sold berries.
I used to say, have a berry good day.
But the--
Of course
you were probably like four.
Yeah. I was super chippy.
I always wear a gingham
and I actually bought overall to the thrift store.
Of course. Dress the part
Thank you.
But it gave me such an appreciation for food,
and I think it's why I love to cook now.
So I love that not only the volunteers providing this food
for the people that need it
but they're bringing kids there to show them how it's done
and to show literally you can plant a seed
and plant a seed of good deed at the same time.
These are the kinds of things where I think I sit around
and fantasize about what the world could be.
And it is.
It is, it is a nice reminder.
And next we've got a little bit of Cardi B news
Yahoo Life reports that Cardi just announced
she has a brand new Cardi B doll
and she designed it all herself
in collaboration with Real Women Are,
which is a doll company that's dedicated to diversity
and inclusion.
Cardi says she never saw a doll
that looked like her growing up.
And she was inspired by her two-year-old daughter Kulture
and her nieces.
And you can pre-order the Cardi B doll now.
Now, did you ever play with dolls Drew?
You know, I did have some barbies for sure
but my big thing was matchbox cars
and I collected them,
and then I had like a little recipe box
and they were all on index cards,
like their color, their make,
the green Pinto type of thing.
Well, I think it's great that she's making this doll
because she didn't have it growing up,
I didn't have, well
I would like to say I didn't have a doll that didn't
(Drew laughs)
Here's the deal,
I did a doll that looked like me
because I had a cabbage patch kid
I asked three Christmases that I finally got it
and look there I am, that's me
Oh no!
Look at how cute you are
I look like a walking, living cabbage patch kid.
I always...
There see
look at me. Not so bad kid, right?
That's what I was thinking.
I love him and you.
Thanks so much.
My cabbage patch kid's name was Randy.
Of course it was
He came with it, I would never have chosen that
No offense to all the Randys out there watching, thank you.
(laughter)
Well, if you're feeling Randy
See, I love that name for that reason.
Cause it has a double entendre.
All right, next, we're always looking for ways
to shop more consciously
and now just in time for Women's History Month
there's a new way to do it.
A collaborative called Empower At Work
does amazing work all around the world,
educating and empowering women
who power the fashion industry.
It would not exist without them
and they provide the tools to garment workers
in countries across Asia and Africa.
And now you can directly contribute to their work.
Vogue reports that you can now find
the "Fashion Makes The Change" Round up button.
When you check out at 40 different major fashion retailers
across the US or you're checking out online,
you can now donate any amount of change
you have in your pockets or dollars, whatever it is
it will go directly to these women.
Macy's, Nordstrom, Michael Kors
are just a few of the brands that are participating.
There are so many on this list.
And I think knowing what this is going to
is really important so that we can be familiar
and be like, yes this is going directly to these women
who make clothes.
Yeah, and you think,
okay so I round, let's say it's 14.90
and say round up to $15.
You're like, what's 10 cents going to do.
But if we all start chipping in 10 cents, we can make,
we can raise some real money for these women.
I completely agree.
And that's the point.
Well, and when we're not shopping
or shopping online,
what we're doing with streaming
and a lot of people, they're going to go back
and re-watch some old favorites.
And if you're thinking of re-watching "Friends",
well now is the perfect time.
Let me explain.
Apartment Therapy reports a website called
Best Value Schools will pay you $1000
just to watch the first five seasons of "Friends".
Now why? They're picking five people for the job,
and here's how you qualify.
You have to love "Friends",
you have to be ready to document your experience
on social media.
and you can apply on the Best Value Schools website
till March 31st.
And I think it's just because
people are relating to that song right now.
No one said your life was going to go this way.
(clapping)
Yeah, if you can relate to that song
here's a little help for you.
We're going to pay you just to watch "Friends"
I mean, this is a couch potato's dream
Do you think I could find a gig,
they could pay me to watch "Golden Girls"
because I could do that all day, every day.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
You and a lot of people I know.
Well "Friends" ran for 10 seasons
and we all remember those iconic sets.
Look at who got to visit the "Friends" set.
This one's Monica's kitchen.
Oh My God
Yeah,
it's the Shedd aquarium penguins.
I started watching this and I just got lost in a trance
and it's like, it's just so cute.
Why is it so cute Rossie?
Remember that time he had a weird dream about penguins
on the set of "Friends"?
Oh no, that was reality, look (laughter)
Why does this make me happy?
I don't know, but I could watch it all day long.
Look at him go. All right.
Well then that's it for Drew's News
(upbeat music)